let me ask you a question ah whose idea
was this show so you see that guy right
there in the blue shirt yeah his name -
Chris what's in it Chris right can you
fight Chris
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even had her wings and
today we're joined by Idris Elba is one
of Hollywood's biggest stars with an
extraordinary career in film and
television that spans more than 20 years
a Renaissance man a DJ Andy has his own
fashion line to our set you can also
catch him starring alongside Dwayne
Johnson and Hobbes and Shaw which is set
to theaters on August 2nd Idris although
welcome to the show thank you so much
man you forgot rapper also a rapper you
didn't know well we'll get to that here
in just a sec wait we don't have to but
it just I know that you enjoy a side of
hot sauce with your eggs and steak in
Lemoore I actually do yes how do you
think you'll fare today against the
wings ah it sound pretty confident I'm
pretty confident in his wife because I
fear no one
[Music]
[Music]
all right cool it's pretty decent
all right look you know my mom
west-african cooks with real spices and
everything I was just four years old so
you know I mean you have a good
foundation there I have a good
foundation yeah yeah so I want to start
by mentioning Hobbs and Shawn
specifically your interesting cars which
I know goes much deeper than just the
Fast & Furious franchise and in the film
you drive this motorcycle that can do a
little bit of everything
are you into the cutting edge technology
and gadgets that are showing up in cars
these days are you more of an old-school
Motorhead man I sort of I'm course you
know in between the two cuz I really
really like a chill head I like the
smell of old leather I love the smell
you know gasoline go into the thing but
what's happening with the innovation of
cars and technology is incredible I mean
we are becoming one with our cars you
know you can open your car with your
phone you can turn your AC on before you
get any of the engine
the bike is you remember like Knight
Rider right
a bit like kit and old David happen so
it has like an extension of you you saw
that right and David Hasselhoff had a
decent leather jacket I went for that
look as well so as a lifelong hip hop
obsessive where did recording the intro
to jay-z's American Gangster rank in
terms of your career accomplishments um
it's up there in top five really wrote
oh yeah
because um I have always had this hybrid
dream of being an actor and a musician
and that my music of my films lived
together in one way of one world and
here I was in an American Gangster and
I'm making this film with Denzel it was
a moment in my life and then I hear from
Ridley Scott himself jay-z's gonna do an
album why I gotta be on that album I
said in my brain not to Ridley but to
myself I'm gonna be on the album and so
the next thing you know I'm sending
jay-z this poem I rip my retinas poem
this sonnet I worked with a good friend
of mine an angel and she and I have
pulled together this poem report this
beat together from a boy Chris flame
and we went in send it to jay-z like
this this hope he likes it when you sent
me an email back back saying I don't
like it I [ __ ] love it it's gonna be
on the intro of American Gangster and
that was the beginning of the dream bro
that was the beginning like you know
dream big it can happen for you and then
I'm the topic of rap music hot ones
creator Chris Schoenberger he's obsessed
with that Kino song road man's him which
actually references you cuz I think you
guys are from the same neighborhood
Charlotte okay no he's he's a legend in
in UK hip-hop scene a big uptick in oh
yeah so for our viewers who are maybe
not familiar with British hip-hop can
you give us your top 5 Dead or Alive UK
Edition okay I'm gonna say no particular
order demon boys which some of you would
not know but I was one of the first rap
groups that I fell in love of in England
I'm gonna put black twang on there I'm
gonna put the London posse on there I'm
gonna have to put storm Z on there I
have to put dizzy on there I'm gonna
have to put gigs on there I mean I know
that six and I can count but it's just
you know in terms of UK hip hop right we
have to remember is that for a long time
we emulated them at America we emulated
them we even wrapped in American accents
just because we 40 was cool LA and we
didn't think our music would be accepted
and now we don't even listen to my own
rap music as much you know we have our
own labels we have our own stars and it
feels very good
very healthy
[Music]
was it light with no heavy man what was
he doing
what's all you sweat so in 2017 you
released a documentary that followed
your year-long journey training for
eventually competing and winning your
kickboxing professional debut and maybe
this sounds like a bizarre question but
when you knock someone out the water
slurp huh it's a technique sucka
talk about engines like a cooling
technique Oh got slep it in an IRA to
them innovative when you knock someone
out is it just a pure thrill of victory
feeling or is there a part of you that's
like concerned for the other person
that's a great question because in my
training the concern lives inspiring
when you hit something really hard
inspiring your concern for them you know
because they're concerned for you
they're letting you know when they hit
you that I got you keep your arm up keep
your ribs covered or whatever but when
you're in a fight situation and I did
not notice I've never been a
professional fire into that moment there
is no concern for each other he came out
to take my head off and he felt I was 43
at the time like this guy was way
younger than me he was gonna beat me but
wasn't having that so there's no room
for concern is the short answer you just
have to go in there and it's like man
against man you know Dwayne Johnson
gives you one free shot where and how do
you hit him if I had to hit Dwayne one
time and and no disrespect Wayne I love
you pal but I'm going for your neck Yeah
right in there bro because like you know
I just at least if you get up from it
you be winded and I would have reached
halfway down the block by that sound
shortly I'm going for the neck okay
very strategic all right you're ready to
move on a four lucky dog year of the dog
oh yeah
[Music]
well I have to tell you I expected some
real competition and these homes will
remember we'll remember it just say this
[Laughter]
last time I was in London was in 2017
and I got a crash course in British
slang from Charlie slots so here I'm
hoping you can take me to finishing
school but first things first
okay can you explain what cockney
rhyming slang is they come from your
neck of the woods so company rhyming
slang I have to give you a brief history
in in in London history the cockneys are
a community there are people you might
have seen them they have these amazing
pearl laced jackets there you know
parade those are the companies and you
can only be a cockney if you were born
within the three-mile radius of a church
called the bow church and it was called
the bow bells because when the church
rang you could hear the bells for three
miles if it was outside of the three
miles you could not be a cockney but if
you could hear the bells of in the
throughout it is you are technically a
cockney now cockney rhyming slang was
almost like code speak you know like you
ever been to jail no meaning but
irrelevant in jail they would say you
know possibly the bloody blah to mean
the bloody blood right and cockney
rhyming slang did a similar sort of
thing is kind of like you know I'm gonna
go to the apples and pears and that
would rhyme with stairs so you're going
up the apples and pears stairs so you
want to say to your boy I'm gonna be
meet me at the apples and pears you
don't want anyone else to know
yes that's what that's what cockney
rhyming slang is what is a crap when
someone says a crap what's a crap a crap
is the sneakers in a so shoes like you
know you've got your crepes is that I
don't know where it comes from I think
it might be French derivative but it's
your crap in it it's like yeah what do
they mean when they say Bob's your uncle
cuz I'm always like my uncle Steve I got
another one name bro it's a confirmation
that you're going down the right
you know saying this like you know go
down the road make a left you see the
shop on your right Bob's your uncle it's
there and it means it just means
confirmation you're there what would you
want idris elba to mean in cockney
rhyming slang be more like I like that
hey you know what I'm gonna do me LD
Giselle what's it like no study on today
mm-hmm no solos Carly on China
you can Caliente no mass that's pretty
good that's terrible that's well done
all right so every Korean segment on our
show called explain that grammar we do a
deep dive under guess Instagram cool
interesting pictures that need more
context don't do that
so I'll bust out the laptop I'll show
you the picture and you just tell me the
bigger story does that sound good
really that's going down he's gonna dump
all right I'm sweating over here though
first things first
here you are Tyrion we hey Arsenal
legend who's your favorite gunner of all
time favorite guna of all time has to be
Ian right Ian right I love you tre
you're my guy but Ian's right it was
alleged you know he's uh he's from my
neck of the woods just seeing him step
into the awesome shirt killer as one of
the greatest strikers asked was ever
seen was like there is hope for all of
us so yeah we got to Eni all right here
you are getting a fit off what did his
royal Birthday Ball in 2004 is that true
that you met Diddy when you were 14
years old not 14 it was about 18 years
old I was did he was doing these
incredible and I have to say shout-out
to Diddy for doing these he was doing
these incredible talks as part of music
seminars and we had this one music
cinema seminar in London in Islington
and this is just before the height of
bad boy came alive and in rows in P
Diddy and I got to ask him a question
and everyone was like but this is Puff
Daddy from America you know being small
the whole lot and then as he was leaving
everyone was standing up clapping and he
came down the middle and I put my hand
up
and he missed me oh [ __ ] okay I love you
did and that was the other day I know I
know you expected the high-five it never
came but however I was like this I
missed him buddy
he definitely saw me that was my G and
then one more for you do you have a
lasting memory from this party at
Greenhouse Ti Drake and then of course
Nipsey Hussle I met Drake that night and
nipsey that night and I just remember
they were you know Nick's he was a fan
of the wire trick too and you know they
were giving me mad love
we were just in this group just lads
having fun there's a couple more
pictures from that series at a run they
probably has but what was interesting
about the wire is that I you know my
character stringer Bell and Avon and we
Bey you know we we captured the
imagination of the rap stars we captured
the rap the imagination of the hip-hop
stars just because that was partly their
journey most rappers had you know been
on the streets at some point and the
wire represented them so I was like you
know grandfathered into the culture and
and the rappers and I definitely had a
you know until they heard me speak - oh
I'm a go [ __ ] amazing y'all right
you're like stringer what
you know Kevin said I'm getting high I
kind of get where he's going oh now
we're talking okay know it says taste no
evil I mean who puts that on on their
marketing Hellfire Detroit failed to
taste no evil this is good this is by
far my favorite really favorite yeah
uh-huh
mm-hmm so in a 2010 New York Times
profile you talked about being
fascinated by the career of somebody
like Daniel day-lewis who is able to
have this viable huge career in acting
while simultaneously maintaining a
private life and since that time we've
gotten further away from that version of
a movie star
do you have any thoughts on how
celebrity is handled in the media like
do you still yearn for that sense of
privacy that's a great question because
you know my career spans over a couple
of decades I was talking to my publicist
about this you know how the trends have
changed you get you know we want to know
more we want to know more you want to do
we don't just want to do an interview we
want to eat hot wings really you know we
wanna and that is a sign of the times
you know I mean I feel like and I have a
theory behind it it may be controversial
but reality TV changed the game because
you don't have to watch an actor pretend
to cry when you can watch real people
cry in real life and then you start to
see the difference between acting and
reality when someone's prepared to bare
their soul on TV why gonna watch an
actor so that changed the game for all
of us because they were like yeah he's
so mysterious who cares I got someone
over here who's bearing their soul out
in their their real life and I get to
know them they are my personality in
real life is probably way more
disappointing that my characters I get
to play I play way more interesting
characters than Who I am in real life
however that said I don't miss the days
where you could be mysterious I don't
actually miss that I don't like the
obsession with celebrity
I think it's unhealthy it's unhealthy
for a lot of reasons but if you're gonna
everyone's gonna have a
a camera on their phone you're going to
expect an obsession with celebrity
you're going to expect that people used
to walk around with water graph books
now they don't they want the picture
[Music]
good tasting what what okay mm-hmm are
you as a plan put that one over there
[Music]
let me try that there you go you see
ones an it's like a percolate it's like
um it's like a cooling system cooling it
down just some swollen so I know that
getting the role of string of bow on the
wire it was a huge break in your career
and then of course that show is aged so
well constantly topping lists of the
best TV shows ever made is it true that
David Simon didn't know that you have an
accent when you were cast yeah we love
it it's cool
so David Simon specifically told Alexa
Fogel who is the casting director listen
this is about Baltimore well see no
non-americans for any of these roles I
need people that can really relate to
the story I'm trying to tell here which
is a very fair thing to ask for
considering how observant he is of the
culture so Alexa foger was a casting
director that was really into seeing new
talent and she met me and she said I
love you I kind of bring you into this
audition but then promise me you can
tell them you from East London I'm like
what that walk in there you got to talk
with your accent you live in Brooklyn
right you got sit in the barbershop talk
all day I was like okay
so my first audition I walked in there
and I had to just pretend she's outside
the doors like remember
hey Harry years into Shelby Lane Jenna I
set it in I did my first edition and
David Sanger was among great great
I still one more time into seven ever go
and then the fourth audition they
changed the tactics on me because by
this point I was good with the accent
like boom I was walking in and I go what
up David what up man what's good nearly
old is that yeah great and the Irishman
so I talk to me goes hey address I
talked to her about your life huh yeah
yeah just talk to me so waiver now this
is the moment of truth because my
parents told me not to lie you know I
mean you look someone in the eye and be
honest I have lied it's never worked out
for me so I was looking at this guy
thinking yeah girl you know I'm not from
Brooklyn don't us we were from just ask
me to read the lines and we could get
out of here and he was Irish so I could
tell ya this twinkle in his eye he's
like no come on brother boyfriend
and I said listen mate I'm from London
bro I'm born and raised in East London
yeah I would Alexa done don't fire Alexa
but she told me not to tell you guys and
he jumped over and I knew it I blew it
David I knew it
dad was like wow okay and true story he
said you know we just want to give you
the job I'm nearly burst into tears
because it was a tough time for me at
times and he said I'm not gonna give you
every one but I think he could play
string a bell and he told me why and
that was it it's amazing true story
[Music]
Oh was being the top scorer for the
under nine scanning town football club
your first brush with greatness well
okay let me just get this straight
the out can in town under nine sting
that was a joke that wasn't real I just
said that for the commercial you talk
about the I detest commercial were to
ask the new shots I said what you're
trying to do did taking the 2017 title
for britain's rear of the year have any
tangible effect on your life
[ __ ] showed up
and I didn't even know I was nominated
they made me a bit interested today who
fun is looking at my ass to nominate me
for having a box Jesus Christ that is
hot which made you feel more famous
hosting the Met Gala or hosting us and
how the Met garner I had Lady Gaga
coming up to me Rihanna and Beyonce
coming up to me shaking my hand I felt
super famous and Anna Wintour bless her
heart you know she she championed me as
someone who should host it half the
people didn't know who I was
hello who okay he was underwire yeah
yeah my dad seen that that was great
apparently great but um when I did her
now
[Music]
I did a Chanel that was one of the
pinnacles in my life first of all
because godly boy I can't even speak my
mouth is actually numb careful run guys
don't get hit my eyes yeah yeah careful
run there anyway it was a pinnacle I got
to speak to a new New York audience
about my journey in New York being on
SNL and being a host it was incredible
alright address okay bro are you ready
to move on no I mean yeah like I said
man I am gonna be the hottest hottest
hot one
ain't I scared of nothing with nobody
you know what I tell my children is he
Winston we as I scared of nobody nothing
let me ask you a question funny sure
sure
let me ask you a question uh whose idea
was this show so you see that guy right
there and the blue shirt yeah his named
Chris what's in it Chris right can you
fight Chris you might have to but you
have to talk about this we already have
a bright ideas coming up in your little
brain box over there Jesus claim about
to pass out so when you're not doing
summer blockbusters or doing cult TV
shows like Luther I know that you're a
globe-trotting DJ who it's everyplace
from Coachella to Ibiza and your roots
behind the turntables they go really
deep can you explain the pirate radio
scene for those who are unfamiliar yeah
absolutely the pirate radio scene really
started off somewhere in the 70s I want
to say 70s early 80s there was a radio
station called Caroline radio which was
like this radio station that pitched up
on a ship why they did that is because
they found that it could hijack a
frequency and the people that control
that basically couldn't find him because
it wasn't about and they were like who
is this station Radio Caroline it killed
it it started a trend cut to the mid
eighties early nineties it was all the
rage especially for urban music for
black music where we want to talk about
our neighborhood we want to talk about
things that we see every day
excuse me I just spat all over your it's
okay we're in this together
let me Debbie damage your swing over
there boy thank you I worked on pirate
radio for about two years I was on two
stations paradise FM and climax of them
I had a Saturday show daytime ladies and
gentleman I was mr. Kipling welcome to
the show between 6:00 and 8:00 p.m. and
I'm sorry the artists is long I know I
know because I'm trying to talk this
[ __ ] off
but long story short I depart for two
years and it was great it was great
I wasn't famous for me I had a great
show I loved it I used to do
tokens I used to play new music and
pirate radio was really one of the first
places you could have specialists urban
music what's the biggest mistake that
you can make as a DJ Shaquille O'Neill
once told me it's not playing enough
songs for the ladies ah what are you
doing what are you doing
[Music]
so this is the last dab we call it the
last dab because it's tradition around
here to put a little extra what on the
last are you talking about you don't
have to if you don't want to Oh
showing you gonna drive gently like that
what did I tell you before I started I'm
the hottest hot one that's true I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna do a freestyle
off to this put it out and you can play
it with the show but it's gonna be
called the hot hot hot one we would be
honored
would you really yeah you know what I'm
gonna dab all right
bottoms up you got I told my son today
he was talking about the slugs it's
scared of slugs and he said you know
he's moved his lady and the slug came in
and he was like get it out it she was
like don't you get it out so you have to
get it out I told him sometimes yeah
just do it but you gotta do it like
you're mad at it just like I did their
[ __ ] I told you when you see the slug
next time ya pick it up and throw it up
and it will hide your fear slug that
wing slug that slug at the window
alright address here we are at the
summit of mount Scoville and we've
touched on a lot of things today but one
thing that we haven't touched on yet yes
is cats you're starring in a film
adaptation of the classic stage show and
here on wing 10 we're hoping that we can
put some of the most hotly contested fan
debates to rest once and for all
great which song bangs harder the rum
tum tugger or mr. Mistoffelees whoo
mr. mostafa listen Mike I think the
internet seems obsessed with the digital
fur technology going on in the trailer
is it live-action or is it CGI it is a
first of its kind when I saw the -
excuse me when I saw the previz for what
we were gonna look like I was blown away
and then finally is cats a deeply
layered allegory about Victorian
politics in our own salvation or is it
just about cats the truth is the writing
is very deep there's a very beautiful
tale at the bottom of it no pun intended
you know cats have nine lives but humans
we don't know this but we are part of
maybe nine types of personalities I
suspect that there is a little bit of a
thing going on we're around that theory
and cats have in nine months fascinating
stuff and Idris Elba look at you sure
her HAP's the hottest hot one in the
history of hot ones and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you my friend this camera
this camera this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
all right ladies and gentlemen I just
want to tell you right now my face is
burning okay as much as I want to tell
you what I'm doing in my life right now
I'm just gonna go to the bathroom and
wash it with cold water apart from that
I want to tell you the t-shirt I'm
wearing is a to our set t-shirt
shameless plug
I also have a rap album coming I don't
know what it's called yet might call it
hot ones go watch Hobbes in sure it's a
lot of fun
some really great moments in it I think
you can enjoy it Sean and the entire hot
wings crew except for Chris you're a
madman
don't ever talk to me again or you never
spoke to me my life but not
- again you guys are amazing thank you
very much for having me on the show I
really enjoyed it please this way and by
the way I love the start of you you're
Christians are great thank you it's
really busy at the state of your head
Wow thank you
oh good pretty stuff thank you guys
you're a good team man Wow hey what's
going on hot ones fans this is Sean
Evans checking in to say thank you so
much for watching today's episode and if
you were ever on the fence about the
subscription box this month is the month
you will get the hot ones trio pack
including the sold out Carolina Reaper
Edition last app that's right the only
way to get the Carolina Reaper Edition
last tab is in the subscription box and
the only way to get the subscription box
is through heat mist heat mist calm heat
mist calm to order be careful out there
dab heads and Godspeed
[Music]